[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  Tony SAP Blake is Southeast Asia's  largest lake one of the things that  makes the Tonle Sap special is that it  expands in the rainy season and  contracts in the dry season I've come  out with some fishermen to see what  they're catching  so the fishermen set out a net last  night and right down here in the boat is  what they caught one thing that strikes  me immediately is that these are almost  all juvenile fish so not only fish but  also turtle shrimp snails and check this  out  aquatic snake and so this is one of the  things that the total ESOP is famous for  the Tonle Sap is home to the world's  largest aquatic snake harvest and this  time of year the aquatic snake harvest  Peaks the waters come up and it forces  the snakes into the trees and into the  vegetation  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]